okay it's time for hate reott mail what
is hatred mail quick reminder it's like
email for words from your racist grandma
on steroids Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right no
introduction needed for this week's
hatred mail recently some hatred males
have required some introduction for
context but not this week's it's
straight up old-style
Hitler apologia take a listen if Hitler
wanted to do his Jew killing stuff
you're a free [ __ ] a David Pakman why
did he not like Jews David the leaders
of the Jews sold the Germans out during
first world war
god damn you liberals are weak Hitler's
was logical if you understand history I
think that's my problem I don't have a
full understanding of history and
therefore Hitler does not seem like the
most logical and sensible actor in in
the historical record I guess I never
thought about it that way use the coupon
code hate reott 40 when you sign up for
membership you save 40% and hatreds cry
it's like sending a middle finger to the
hatreds you're saying you know what your
continued barrage of vile disgusting
depraved and delusional anti-semitic
attacks on David Pakman or David Parkman
as many people write in and say are not
going to be allowed to stand and the
coupon code hatred for tea it upsets
hatreds when people sign up with that
code so I encourage you to do it